hi this is presh talwalkar and today i'm
going to explain a math trick of how you
can multiply numbers just by drawing
lines
let's say you want to multiply 12 by 13.
for this one we'll draw one line and for
the two we'll leave a little bit of
space and we'll draw two lines
for the other number we'll draw lines in
the other direction
now we'll group together different lines
and we'll count the dots
here we have
six different dots
in the middle
we have five different dots
and on the other side we have one dot
and that's the answer 156.
we'll do another example
for 15 by 21 we start out by drawing one
line
then we'll leave a little bit of space
and draw five lines
and the other number we draw lines in
the other direction so we draw two lines
here
and one line here
we will again group the different lines
here we have five dots
in the middle
we have 11 dots
and the other end we have two dots
we'll need to make one adjustment
because we have eleven we'll need to
carry this one over
which will make three
and our answer is three fifteen
we can even do this for bigger numbers
123 we start out with
one line then with some space two lines
uh with some more space three lines
and we draw the other lines for the
other number in the other direction
we again group the lines
we have three dots here
eight dots here
14
8
and 3. once again we're going to have to
carry this one over
so that's our answer it'll be
nine thousand four hundred and eighty
three
you can even use this trick
when a number includes zero
uh
but one thing when you draw this line
you should still keep draw the line but
put it in a different color or a
different marking
and the trick will be
that we don't count any of the dots for
that line
so when we make the grouping we have
three dots here
for the second arrangement we're only
going to count the dots
for the non-zero lines so we have six
dots here we don't count the any of the
intersections for the zero line
in the middle we again ignore the zero
line which makes seven
here we have two dots and two dots here
so you can even use this method when
you have a number that includes zero
the method
the reason it works you can even use it
for algebraic equations let's say you
have x plus 2y
times x plus 3y
we'll draw one line for the x
and we'll draw two lines for the 2y and
we'll keep it in blue
we'll put all the x's in black
and
the y's in blue
the other number we draw the lines in
the other direction
and again we make groupings
so here we have six dots and because
both of the lines are blue
that means it's y squared
in the middle
we have five dots
and these are the intersections of a
black and blue line
which means it will be an x and a y
on the end we just have one dot and
that's for two black lines so it's x
squared
so that's the answer
i hope you enjoyed this trick
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory
you can follow me on twitter at
preshtalwalker and get my ebooks at
amazon